[Music]
roseann is no stranger to controversy
it's hard to forget her much criticized
national anthem performance in 1990 and
it's not the first time her tweets have
landed her in hot water
in fact on the day the reboot premiered
she accused a school shooting survivor
of giving a Nazi salute the fallout
prompted this photo shoot from 2009 to
resurfaced in it
roseann dressed as Hitler complete with
a swastika armband still Rosanna
maintained pushing the boundaries was in
her blood
my parents my grandparents were
socialist and because of that I always
was political she also talked openly
about her struggle with mental illness I
totally lost touch with reality in a big
big way I didn't know what the truth was
and while Rosanna has apologized for her
tweet today she's often been defiant in
her position as a person who's taking
the hard hits and lost the jobs and has
like been fired me for stuff I've said
maybe it's not so fair that only some
people have to apologize for what they
say and some you know get a pass
[Music]
[Applause]